in manchester city center
all paramedic ian is trying to do is
save lives
but almost every day he and his
colleagues are on the receiving end of
vicious attacks
as i'm treating this person
and the assailant ran towards the
patient
and whilst i was down at his head kicked
me in the left side of the temple
sending me actually into the road whilst
working in 2019
ian almost lost his life i think if i'm
honest it was the first time
first time i've ever felt vulnerable the
first time i've actually felt
i wasn't safe in my city that i look
after
it did make me question whether i'm in
the right profession
data from the nhs shows that three and a
half thousand ambulance staff
reported being assaulted over the last
year a rise of 32 percent from five
years ago
it's got a fish eye lens it's why from
today
paramedics across the country are being
issued with body-worn cameras
to protect them and reduce levels of
violent abuse
it will give the crews confidence to
know that they are getting protected and
that there is
uh potential uh to deter people from
causing violence against them
but ultimately as well it will help in
prosecutions yes yes i received i'm
making away now
successful trials led to the north west
ambulance service introducing cameras in
march
they recorded hundreds of incidents on
the first weekend alone
whilst bodies representing healthcare
staff welcome the move
they say more support to protect
paramedics is needed
they're certainly not a magic bullet
they really will
need to be backed up by a whole range of
other policies that that look at how to
keep people safe and prevent these
incidents happening and what we wouldn't
want to see is people having a false
sense of security
ian was one of the first paramedics in
the northwest to work with a body cam
recorded incidents have already led to
arrests
i'm hoping that moving forward
the levels of aggression and the numbers
of assaults
will drop dramatically it will make
people think
do i really want to do this yes yes i
would imagine this is the same male that
abused me earlier on i'll willingly go
and have a look joe
ian says he and his colleagues instantly
feel safer
with the ability to use a body cam this
feature will help with crucial evidence
gathering
against those that abuse and attack our
crucial frontline workers
in taman rashid sky news manchester